he's tiny and he's starving but his
mother's milk
simply doesn't have the nutrition needed
to feed him properly
jason gasol is two months old and weighs
just five and a half
pounds
[Music]
he should be double the size at least
next to him his two and a half year old
brother sleeps he's tiny as well
in this part of guatemala everyone is
hungry
just like the brothers there's a food
crisis here that has gone on for years
and it's getting worse
volunteer aid workers a handful of them
like sophia latona
are all at stopping families like
jason's from starving to death
the reality is that his body is so frail
because of malnutrition
and everything that happens to him will
be a consequence of him being too weak
to fight back
the tell-tale signs of malnutrition are
[Music]
everywhere
children with bloated stomachs get
almost no help
there's very little their families can
do for them
little food and parasite infested water
is a deadly mix guatemala
now has one of the worst malnutrition
rates in the world
this quiet crisis is being caused by
climate change
the weather is now so variable growing
enough food has become all but
impossible
this is called the dry corridor it
stretches through the central american
countries of el salvador
honduras nicaragua and here in eastern
guatemala
crops wither in blistering sunshine
after being lashed
with unseasonal reins
sofia is checking on a mother who is due
to give birth
we find her and her newborn baby in this
hut
this is abject poverty a struggle
every day to survive she's about four
and a half pounds a new life brought
into a world with little hope
you know they don't have a house they
cannot rent a house the crops did not
work well
so now you have two or three sets of
families living under the same roof
because that will provide them with more
hope
to get food between them and while some
of the women take care of the kids some
can go out and work a little
get some food they're just creating this
small community of women who are
supporting each other
and this is just really like an act of
survival yes it's an act of survival
yeah
the mountains and the valleys of the dry
corridor appear magnificent
and green but there's little in the way
of crops growing here
landslips caused by flooding are common
recent hurricanes have made it worse
many farmers have simply given up and
left many joining
so-called caravans heading to the united
states
environmental migrants not criminals
leaving homelands
that simply can't support them
well they have pretty meager crop yields
here as a rule
even in the best of times but now a
combination of
no rain intense heat
and a hurricane means that 100
of the local crop has been destroyed
they will get nothing this year
what they're saying is that the weather
is changing all the time
there's absolutely no guarantee when the
rains will come when the right sun will
be there
and then of course they're getting these
wild weather in the shape of a hurricane
and that is making life here really
really difficult
farmers like eduardo roque try to hold
on it's all gone
but he showed me his failing crop he's
fighting a losing battle
against the elements
produced
these mountain communities are all
desperately poor all lacking in proper
food and water
but they share another trait there are
virtually no men
they've left to find work to feed their
families
and many never return
many of these children are likely to
find themselves environmental migrants
as well
born into an environment that can't
sustain them
stuart ramsey sky news guatemala